mappe punti fra storia e cultura ma mi
vorrei soffermare sul mio nome
napolitano vengo da trento napolitano a
trento sono un po strano io mi sento
proprio un ponte tra due culture perché
mio padre napoletano mia madre trentina
in più nel mio percorso ho sposato una
cinese in cui parla tedesco trento
qualcuno pensa che si parli tedesco in
realtà quando voi
aspetto quando è arrivato a trento
l'uscita della stazione trovata e questa
statua la sorte dei tanti alighieri che
è stata fatta in un periodo in cui
trento non era italia perché la gente
parlava italiano perché si sentivano
italiani e tra questi miei concittadini
c'è questo personaggio qua cesare
battisti che come detto ha fatto tante
cose
credeva molto nel fatto che 30 dovesse
diventare italia non voglio raccontarvi
però questa storia vuole raccontare una
cosa che battisti ci ha regalato due run
geografo ha scritto un libro
questo libro a questa mappa la mappa e
del 1115 trento era ancora austria
la mappa in italiano quando l'ho
guardato iniziato a incuriosirmi e
volevo confrontarla con quella che è poi
la 30 di adesso
così ho giocato un po con i dati li ho
creato questa visualizzazione che mi
mostra al passaggio com'era 30 una volta
gli permette di comparare le due storie
e allora questa mappa mi diventa un
ponte tra passato e presente e mi mostra
delle cose a cui non ho mai pensato
non ho mai pensato che via garibaldi via
mazzini personaggi del risorgimento e
credo proprio non potevano esserci
quello che mi interessa adesso spostarvi
se sul presente su quella mappa che c'è
sopra perché la mappa che c'è sopra è
veramente la mappa più aggiornata che
conosco di trento e alla mappa che viene
da un progetto che si chiama open street
map è un progetto che nasce più di dieci
anni fa con l'obiettivo di creare un
bene comune raccogliere dati che
descrivono map
chiunque di voi può partecipare può
disegnare una strada assegnargli un nome
dichiarare il tipo di asfalto inserire
un negozio il numero di piani
dell'edificio
tutto quello che abbiamo inserito
diventa una mappa i risultati sono
questi
perché non voglio star proprio davanti i
dati sono questi questa guerra mappa di
open street map è quella la mappa che
permette avete visto più spesso online
non mi interessa sapere cuore la più
bella assolutamente
quello che mi interessa è porre
l'attenzione sulla quantità di
informazioni che si sono su questa
perché quella è generosità delle persone
persone che hanno usato il loro tempo e
loro amore per descrivere la propria
città se non sono persone di potenza
sono persone che sono passate qua che in
qualche mossa rimasti colpiti hanno
dovuto lasciare un segno quello che c'è
sulla mappa è solo la punta dell'iceberg
sotto ci sono dei dati che permettono di
rappresentare quella mappa in tanti modi
diversi
e allora ecco che possiamo vederlo ad
acquarello piace non piace è una mia
amica la usa per fare la carta da pacco
dei reali oppure possiamo anche
rappresentare le tre dimensioni per i
dati che ci sono ma non solo
possiamo anche trasformarla per
chiedergli di luisi tutti i punti che ci
sono a potenza oppure di rendere questa
mappa tangibile per aumentare la
dimensione l'esperienza che una persona
può avere la facilità con cui queste
mappe vengono create ha fatto sì che sia
usata tantissimo negli ultimi militari
anche ad una catastrofe abbiamo bisogno
di dati
abbiamo bisogno amata aggiornate le
persone partecipano si confrontano
questi ragazzi quanti a sono un sacco
perché sono ragazzi e kathmandu living
lab un laboratorio che sa kathmandu che
si è preparato sapevano che prima o poi
si sarebbe stato il terremoto
loro sono fuori dal laboratorio di
kathmandu dopo le scosse per paure che
era in altre scosse
così stanno facendo stanno inserendo
dati stanno aggiornando la mappa degli
aiuti umanitari
quello che accade poi è che questo non
soltanto nel caso di catastrofe ma anche
luoghi dove probabilmente non c'è
interesse rappresentarli e stata una
bidonville perché un'azienda dovrebbe
raccogliere dati abi non villa
ma le persone si vivono allora nasce
questo concetto rendere visibile ciò che
è invisibile
una capacità che ampio open street map e
quale tornare sul ponte della cultura in
una città ci sono tante comunità è un
caro amico non si dica che erano nate o
tempestini dopo aver chiacchierato con
lui si parlava del fatto che a prato
siamo forte comunità cinese e della
difficoltà che hanno il cinismo e
comunicare i nomi dei posti dei luoghi
allora iniziati a raccogliere i cinesi
di prato e assieme hanno iniziato a
cambiare i toponimi di prato in cinese
in alcuni casi era proprio nelle
traduzioni precise in altri casi invece
il nome di scuola lingua sanpaolo
scritta in cinese anche se non li se non
lo so quello che è invece è la grande
scuola dove andiamo a parlare italiano
quindi ha unito questa mappa le varie
comunità fra di loro e non è un lavoro
così difficile come può sembrare
vi riporto a trento un po più la di
trento
tra poco
l'importo in un paese che si chiama
vervò che una volta era comune 900 metri
730 abitanti giorno mi chiama chiama
malizia nicola però si trova in val di
non solo mele però il comune ha lavorato
per creare nuovi percorsi hanno creato
dei sentieri
volevo che ci fosse anche l'aspetto
turistico voleva che le persone
conoscessero avevo mappe commerciali
arrivano mostra soltanto la strada poi
scrivono sopra vervò se guardando
intorno per una soluzione di cedono tu
che ne serio quel street ma c'è spicchi
come funziona ci mostri volentieri mi
invitano una sera alle nove di sera vado
nel paese nel bar del paese
venti persone che mi ascoltano il
vecchio del paese responsabile sezione
cacciatori responsabile sentieri varie
persone raccontiamo questo se convincono
ezio e nicola dicono che i mille euro
per il gruppo giovani il gruppo giorno
il verbo al compito di aggiornare la
mappa di averlo 500 euro per le loro
attività 500 euro facciamo un concorso
il concorso e premiare chi sarà il
migliore dopo quattro mesi li chiamano
ne dicono deve decidere che il migliore
e questi sono gli utenti di verbo e di
qua per giorgio come ha fatto un gran
lavoro no piergiorgio non può sempre nei
harlow ma perché no no no piergiorgio no
ma perché poi non conoscendo le
dinamiche tutto non mi sembrava corretto
andare investigare di più sono andato
alla sera la presentazione ufficiale di
questo progetto
chiedo che piergiorgio comai e mi
indicano signora di 86 anni
l'ex maestra della scuola che ha scritto
un libro sui toponimi della val di non e
tutto questa conoscenza questa cultura
la portata anche dentro per street
mapper regalandola così nuovamente al
mondo pertanto il mio messaggio finale
questo che ciascuno di noi è un ponte
fra storia e cultura
c'è alcuno di noi può condividere la sua
mappa per il bene comune
grazie
[Applauso]